>> YET ANOTHER AFRICAN-AMERICAN
MAN, GEORGE FLOYD, HIS MURDER IS
WHY THE COUNTRY HAS GIVEN US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD, TO LEAD.
MY FRIENDS ON THE OTHER SIDE
JUST SAID NO.
AS A BLACK GUY, I KNOW HOW IT
FEELS TO WALK INTO A STORE AND
HAVE THE CLERK FOLLOW ME AROUND
AS A UNITED STATES SENATOR.
I GET THAT, I’VE EXPERIENCED
THAT.
I UNDERSTAND A TRAFFIC STOP, I
UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN I’M WALKING
DOWN THE STREET AND SOME YOUNG
LADY CLUTCH IS HER PURSE AND MY
INSTINCT IS TO GET A LITTLE
FURTHER AWAY BECAUSE I DON’T
WANT ANY ISSUES WITH ANYBODY.
I UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT WHAT I MISS IN THIS ISSUE IS
THAT THE STEREOTYPING OF
REPUBLICANS IS JUST AS TOXIC AND
POISON TO THE OUTCOME OF THE
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES IN
THIS NATION.
THAT’S THE ISSUE.
>> Sean: THAT WAS SENATOR TIM
SCOTT’S VERY POWERFUL SPEECH ON
THE SENATE FLOOR TODAY AFTER
DEMOCRATS BLOCKED THE SENATE
REPUBLICANS POLICE REFORM BILL.
HE JOINS US WITH A REACTION
ALONG WITH LINDSEY GRAHAM.
HE MAY BE GIVING YOU A RUN FOR
YOUR MONEY AND I MEAN THIS,
FIRST OF ALL, SENATOR SCOTT,
NOBODY SHOULD BE FOLLOWED IN ANY
STORE BECAUSE OF THE COLOR OF
THEIR SKIN, THAT’S GOT TO STOP.
WHAT HAPPENED TO GEORGE FLOYD
CAN TAP INTO ANY HUMAN BEING,
NOBODY SHOULD BE STOPPED,
EITHER.
MOST AMERICANS, 90% OF GOOD
AMERICANS AGREE WITH THAT.
YOU MET WITH THE PRESIDENT, YOU
TALKED TO THE CHIEF OF STAFF,
YOU WERE ON THE GROUND ASKING
FOR THE REFORMS AND AS I
UNDERSTAND IT, MY SOURCES TELL
ME EVERYTHING YOU ASKED FOR WAS
IN THE BILL AND MORE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I’LL TELL YOU, THE PRESIDENT’S
RESPONSE TO THE SITUATION HAS
BEEN NEARLY PERFECT.
I ASKED FOR CERTAIN THINGS IN
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER, HE WENT
FURTHER.
I DIDN’T ASK FOR A NATIONAL
DATABASE, I THOUGHT I WAS
OUTSIDE OF OUR REACH BUT THE
PRESIDENT SET I WANT TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM AND HE DID.
ALL WE NEEDED TO COMPLEMENT THE
PRESIDENT’S EXECUTIVE ORDER WAS
THE DEMOCRATS TO SHOW UP AND BE
COUNTED, JUST A FEW DEMOCRATS.
NOT 46, JUST SEVEN DEMOCRATS AND
WE COULDN’T GET SEVEN PEOPLE TO
COME TO THE TABLE AND TAKE IT
SERIOUS ABOUT POLICE REFORM.
INSTEAD WHAT THEY ARE SERIOUS
ABOUT IS USING POLICE REFORM AS
A CAMPAIGN ISSUE THIS NOVEMBER,
THAT IS DESPICABLE.
>> Sean: AND WHAT DID JOE AND
BARACK DO AFTER FERGUSON?
AFTER BALTIMORE, AFTER
CAMBRIDGE, DID THEY DO ANYTHING,
SENATOR?
BECAUSE I REMEMBER THEM DOING A
THING.
>> NOT THAT I CAN RECALL BUT I
DO REMEMBER ONE THING THAT
JOE BIDEN DID IN 1994, HE PASSED
THE CRIME BILL THAT HIS DEMOCRAT
OPPONENT SAID LOCKED UP
DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFRICAN-AMERICAN MEN AND TOOK
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO COME ALONG
AND REVERSE THEIR CARNAGE, THE
DAMAGE, THE DISRESPECT DOWN TO
THE BLACK COMMUNITY.
HE REVERSED IT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE UP FOR THE
BAD DECISIONS OF VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN.
>> Sean: I’VE GOT TO GET OUT
OF NEW YORK.
I’M STUCK WITH CHUCK SCHUMER AND
KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND.
I COULD HAVE SENATOR SCOTT AND
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM AND I’D
BE VERY HAPPY.
THEY HAVEN’T DONE A THING AND I
KNOW YOU ARE VERY CLOSE AS
FRIENDS, BOTH OF YOU AND I
WATCHED THIS TODAY AND I AM
LIKE -- THEY WON’T EVEN HELP THE
PRESIDENT ON THIS?
IS THERE ANYTHING THEY’LL DO?
>> THEY’LL DO WHATEVER IT TAKES
TO GET POWER.
IF YOU NEED TO DESTROY BRETT
KAVANAUGH’S LIFE TO KEEP THE
SEAT OPEN, WE WILL DO IT.
WHAT I WILL DO IS HAVE BRETT
KAVANAUGH, BEING ACCUSED AND
MISTREATED AND HAVING HIS LIFE
TURNED UPSIDE DOWN TO MAKE SURE
THEY CAN FILL THE SUPREME COURT
VACANCY.
WHAT TIM DID TODAY IS IN THE
FACE OF HATRED YOU CANNOT
BELIEVE.
I’VE GOT A LOT OF THINGS THROWN
MY WAY, IT WAS PRETTY DICEY,
NOTHING COMPARED TO WHAT TIM
SCOTT HAS GONE THROUGH.
WHAT HAVE I LEARNED ABOUT TIM
SCOTT?
HE SPEAKS FROM THE HEART, HE
CAN’T BE INTIMIDATED AND HE’S
TRYING TO SOLVE A PROBLEM.
HE’S EXPERIENCED THINGS I HAVE
NOT EXPERIENCED BECAUSE I’M
WHITE.
I’M FROM SOUTH CAROLINA, TIM IS
FROM SOUTH CAROLINA AND TIM TOOK
TO THE FLOOR OF THE
UNITED STATES SENATE TODAY TO
MAKE IT BETTER PARTICULARLY FOR
YOUNG BLACK MEN AND
CHUCK SCHUMER BASICALLY TOLD US,
GO TO HELL, WE CARE MORE ABOUT
THE ELECTION THEN WORKING WITH
SENATOR SCOTT.
PROBABLY A LOW POINT IN MY
CAREER.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW SOMETHING,
SENATOR SCOTT, I LIKE TO LOOK
AT -- JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN IN
POLITICS NEARLY 50 YEARS.
WHAT ABOUT HIS PAST ON
SEGREGATION AND PRAISING ROBERT
BYRD?
THAT’S HIS PAST.
ALSO, LYNDON JOHNSON COUNTED ON
REPUBLICANS FOR THE ’64 CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT AND VOTING ACT.
BARACK AND JOE GAVE US 17 MORE A
MILLION AMERICANS ON FOOD STAMPS
STAMPS, THE WORST RECOVERY SINCE
THE ’40s, LOWEST HOMEOWNERSHIP
RATE IN 50 YEARS.
DONALD TRUMP GAVE US OPPORTUNITY
ZONES THAT THEY DIDN’T GIVE US
IN THE EIGHT YEARS THEY HAD
POWER, ADD TO THAT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM, ADD TO THAT
PRISON REFORM.
HISTORICALLY BLACK COLLEGES, I
LIKE ACTIONS.
YOU KNOW.
>> HIGHER LABOR FORCE
PARTICIPATION RATE IN THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE THE LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE PRECOVID-19 FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, 60 YEAR LOW
FOR WOMEN, WE HAD THE ECONOMY ON
FIRE BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP
UNDERSTANDS THAT FREE MARKETS
AND LEAD TO GREATER FOR
EVERYBODY.
LITERALLY ALL OF THOSE WERE
RISING, THE DEMOCRATS CONTINUE
TO HAVE A MONOPOLY ON MINORITY
VOTES AND CONTINUE TO DELIVER
NOTHING IN RETURN FOR THE
MONOPOLY.
THE DEVALUATION OF A SIGNIFICANT
PART OF THE AMERICAN FAMILY AND
THAT’S GOT TO STOP.
>> Sean: I’VE GOT TO MOVE TO
SOUTH CAROLINA.
WE CAN ALL GO TO HALL’S
STEAK HOUSE TOGETHER.
>> MN AND YOU CAN PAY.
>> Sean: I WILL.
I’LL PROBABLY GET ARRESTED FOR
THAT.
SPEAKER VERY PROUD OF MY FRIEND